>>Lee-Feng: Welcome APEC Googlers and other
folks.
Welcome to the first APEC Speakers at Google
event.
I'm really Lee-Feng Chien, Taiwan site director.
And today we are very excited and very honored
because we have a distinguished special guest,
Winston Fiore.
Probably you know, if you read the internal
news about the recent inspiring journey you
probably know some of his background.
But let me recap a bit.
Winston is a former US Marine and served in
Afghanistan and Senegal.
And he's now spending a year walking 5000
miles around Southeast Asia beginning and
ending in Singapore.
And Winston is about halfway on this trip
and now, and he already has been to Talen,
Laos, Kenan, China, Hong Kong and now in Taiwan.
So we're very excited that he is visiting
Taiwan.
[applause]
And his chief purpose is going to each place
to raise money for a children's charity, with
cleft pallet.
[Inaudible] And that's very impressive.
He's been through a lot of efforts to raise
the money and it's very impressive.
And he also would probably like to share us
his very exciting story in the trip, and also
his experience in using Google tools like
altitude and Google maps.
We chatted, and he is using Google maps for
the trip and apparently and he found some
bugs.
[laughter]
So let's welcome Winston.
[applause]
>>Winston: All right thank you.
I actually have my mic.
>>Lee: Please stand here.
>>Winston: Great.
Can everybody not here hear me?
Okay, thank you, good, thumbs-up.
What an honor.
Hello Google.
>>Audience: Hi
>>Winston: I think this is the first time
I've presented to more locations than people.
[laughter]
Thank you Lee-Feng for that introduction I
appreciate it.
As Lee-Feng mentioned, I am on a 5000 mile,
8000 kilometer yearlong hike through Southeast
Asia.
Through eight different countries in Southeast
Asia to raise money for the International
Children's Surgical Foundation (ICSF) which
is a charity that provides free facial reconstructive
surgeries in developing countries.
So I actually started in Singapore on October
3rd.
And I walked nearly to Southeast China and
then flew to Taipei a couple days ago.
And then on June 1st I'll be headed down to
Kaichung.
So that in a nutshell, I want to provide just
a little bit of background for some you might
be unfamiliar on the cause of cleft repair
which is primarily what this charity does.
So clefts or orofacial clefts are a birth
defect in which there is an opening in the
lip or the pallet, the roof of the mouth which
is caused by incomplete development during
fetal formation.
So it's actually one of the most common birth
defects worldwide, one or two out of every
thousand kids is born with a cleft.
The good news is it can be treated and most
kids can undergo surgery within their first
18 months, which is good.
As far as a cause, there is still no definitive
cause that has been outlined by researchers
but there are a number of factors believed
to lead to the formation of clefts.
So you got syndromic factors meaning that
the cleft occurs as part of a syndrome.
So in this slide you'll see two kids with
what's called stickler syndrome which is a
syndrome that attacks the connective tissue
in the body, mainly collagen.
And so as a result of this syndrome children
are more likely to be born with clefts.
You've got genetic factors, so there are a
number of genes that have been identified
by researchers that are believed to lead to
the formation of clefts.
And then you've got a whole host of environmental
factors.
So things such as the mother smoking during
pregnancy, use and abuse of illicit drugs,
nutritional deficiencies are a big one, what
the mother is eating or not getting while
she's pregnant.
Exposure to certain pesticides, these environmental
factors are believed to lead to the formation
of cleft.
They come in a whole set of, range of shapes
and sizes as you can see.
Ranging from some more milder occurrences
to more extreme occurrence in the last one
there where a cleft just in the soft pallet
to a cleft occurring both in the soft and
hard pallet and then bilaterally on the lips
there which is bad news.
So how did I get this idea?
How did I get the idea to walk 5000 miles
through a part of the world I'd never been
to before to raise money for the small cleft
charity?
It actually all started in Senegal in 2007,
summer of 2007.
I deployed with my Marine Corps unit at the
time to Senegal for three weeks of manual
training with the local Senegalese commandos.
And Senegal's the most Western point in Africa
for some of you who are unfamiliar.
That's me in my platoon, I was embedded with
the mortar platoon at the time this is a photo
of us with our Senegalese counterparts.
But it was my first time in that part of the
world, I'd never been to Africa, I'd never
been to a developing country before.
It was an absolutely amazing experience.
All sorts of culture shock and getting to
witness all the local customs.
So seeing, this would happen all the time
we get like a five minute break in training
and before we could turn around the Senegalese
commandos will be huddled up brewing this
tea, drinking it, they'd invite us over.
There was even a specific sipping sound that
we were expected to make as a sign of politeness.
Men holding hands in that part of the world
is a sign of friendship, but coming from Indiana
it wasn't something I was used to seeing every
day.
Come mealtime all the Senegalese would huddle
around a collective dish of food and eat out
of it together as opposed to individual plates
and that type of individual approach that
we have in the States.
So getting to witness all of these local customs
in this local culture was a tremendous experience.
And it really made me realize how little of
the world I'd seen.
And how much more that I wanted to see.
So I decided then and there that I wanted
to dedicate one year to traveling a part of
the world I'd never been to before.
And I wanted to do so on foot so that I could
hopefully connect with locals as I had in
Senegal.
That being said, it wasn't uncommon for us
to see women carrying these huge jugs of water
on their heads from water pumps that were
miles and miles away from their villages just
to bring drinking water into their homes.
Kids dressed in rags digging through piles
of trash.
Just really sad stuff.
And so I decided that if I was gonna spend
one year walking, that I could potentially
find a good cause and potentially walk for
a cause and walk to help out in some way.
But I didn't how I was going to go about doing
that.
So I headed back to New York where I was living
at the time.
And I started looking at different charities
and different causes out there to get a feel
of what was out there.
And it wasn't long before my dad sent me a
newspaper clipping in the mail about a doctor
by the name of Jeff Williams who had been
leading a perfectly comfortable lifestyle
making very good money as a plastic surgeon
on the faculty, the medical school University
of Texas.
And he began volunteering one or two weeks
out of the year with some of the larger organizations
doing medical missions, lending his services
as a plastic surgeon.
And over the years he kind of became disenchanted
by the way a lot of these organizations were
run, by the way a lot of these missions he
was participating in were managed.
And so he decided in 2005 that the best way
for him to continue doing his work would be
to found his own charity and that's what he
did, the International Children's Surgical
Foundation.
So it was a complete inspiration to read this
story and to read about how this foundation
came to be.
But what really spoke to me was the work that
they were doing.
The cause of cleft repair which is not something
I knew a lot about.
And so I wanted to take a couple minutes to
go over some of the complications associated
with clefts and talk a little bit about what
it is these kids have to live with every day.
So one of the earliest things to occur for
a baby with a cleft are difficulties feeding.
So if a child has a cleft lip, they often
can't perform a proper seal around the bottle
or around the nipple.
And so as a result they're deprived of all
sorts of nutrients that they need to grow
and they end up losing all sorts of weight
when they should be gaining weight as a developing
child.
You've got hearing complications.
Clefts will often affect what's called the
Eustachian tube which regulates the fluid
in and out of the middle ear.
So what happens a lot of times is these kids
will get a buildup of fluid in their ear which
if it isn't drained can become infected and
if that infection isn't addressed it can lead
to permanent hearing loss.
In this slide is a three-year-old Chinese
girl who was actually adopted by a family
in the states.
When they adopted her she had a cleft which
they had repaired which is great.
But she also had two permanently ruptured
eardrums from a dual ear infection that had
persisted for two years without treatment.
And then you've got speaking complications,
obviously clefts affect the mouth and can
lead to all sorts of dental deformities.
And kids have speech impediments as a result
of that.
And also if child with a cleft has experienced
hearing loss, they often can't hear the sound
their own mouths are making and have difficulty
speaking as a result of that as well.
And then lastly, and this is hands down the
complications that spoke to me the most.
And those are all of the social complications
associated with clefts.
It can be hard enough for kids without a facial
deformity to make friends growing up, at school
or on the playground.
But you can just imagine how nearly impossible
it is to have a normal social life when you're
having to live with something like this.
These kids are often kept from attending school,
they can't find jobs when they're older, they
can't raise a family because they're considered
undesirable.
And what I really liked about this cause is
it's such a relatively small amount of money
and a short amount of time, a couple hours
of surgeon's time is all it takes to completely
turn these kids' lives around which really
appealed to me.
So I want to talk a little bit about this
charity in particular because it's something
you may know, there are actually several charities
that tackle this work of cleft repair.
A lot of big names out there.
And so you might be wondering why I chose
to stick with a lesser-known charity.
So I want talk about some the things ICSF
does differently that made me want to get
behind them as opposed to some of the other
charities.
Firstly anybody associated with ICSF does
not draw any sort of salary or compensation.
All the staff, the doctors are 100% volunteer.
So it's an extremely lean charity with very
little overhead and I really like that.
A lot of larger charities will spend tens
of thousands of dollars on office administrators
and special projects coordinators and that
type of thing, and ICSF does not do any of
that.
They don't spend any money on advertising.
A lot of organizations will spend tens of
thousands of dollars on newspaper ads, on
TV commercials which cost a lot of money.
ICSF depends on word-of-mouth and what little
press they get.
So again I really like the lean aspect of
the charity.
Their emphasis on postoperative care.
This was a big one for me.
One of the things that Dr. Williams had noticed
when he was doing this work with other charities
before founding ICSF was a lot of times the
complete and utter lack of postoperative care.
So what would happen is he would go on a mission,
and the day after the last surgery, the surgeons
that he was working with would leave.
Or sometimes the day of the last surgery,
the surgeons would leave.
And I can't tell you how detrimental that
is for these kids who are just within that
first week following the surgery.
All sorts of infections can flare-up.
Pneumonia is a common side effect to the surgery.
And so what ICFS does is they make sure to
stay on that mission for an entire week following
the surgery to make sure that they do those
critical postoperative checkups and address
any issues if they do occur which I really
liked.
Emphasis on quality versus quantity.
Some of you who might be more familiar with
clefts may have heard a cleft surgery is advertised
as only taking 45 minutes of a surgeon's time.
While it is possible in some cases to perform
a surgery that quickly the results are often
sub optimal.
In developed countries, when surgeons in developed
countries are performing surgeries they will
often spend hours on kids in developed countries.
But for whatever reason when these medical
teams and these volunteer teams go to the
Third World to perform surgeries they just
rush through them a lot of times and don't
do a top-notch surgery.
And what I really like about ICSF is they
make sure, they don't believe that kids in
the developing world are any less deserving
of the top notch surgery.
And they spend just as much time on these
kids as doctors in developed world do which
I liked.
Emphasis on training local doctors.
What happens a lot of times is medical teams
will go to a part of the world and they'll
do a medical mission, spend a week or two
there and then get up and leave and never
ever come back.
So there's absolutely no follow through.
And they claim to be training, to emphasize
training local doctors.
But when you're only somewhere for a couple
weeks and never returning, how much training
is really getting done?
So what I liked about ICSF is a return in
the same mission sites at least once a year
to ensure that continuity and training over
the years which is important.
And then lastly ICSF tackles a lot of the
more complicated facial deformities, surgeries
for more complicated facial deformities that
other medical groups won't touch either because
they don't have the expertise or they don't
have the training or they don't have the time.
And I'm gonna show you a couple examples of
that.
This was a 26-year-old Kenyan girl, suffered
from something called orbital plexiform neurofibromatosis.
She was turned down time and time again by
volunteer teams coming through Kenya because
they simply didn't have the expertise or the
time to tackle this surgery.
So wasn't until ICSF came around and was able
to perform the surgery that her treatment
was finally able to be successful.
This is a 26-year-old Pakistani man who suffered
from facial plexiform neurofibromatosis, commonly
known as elephant man syndrome.
Actually suffered so extensively that he attempted
to end his life on two different occasions.
The problem in his case is that there weren't
any surgeons in Pakistan who had the training
to perform the surgery because it's a very
intricate surgery.
And not a lot of surgeons will do it because
they don't have the know-how.
So it wasn't until ICSF came around and performed
this seven-hour surgery that he was finally
able to get a new start.
This is a 19-year-old Peruvian girl who suffer
from congenital fiber lipoma.
This is a particular deformity because what
happens with this is while there is obviously
an initial surgery that's required, there's
also a follow-up surgery that's required a
year later in order for the treatment to be
successful.
So she was actually treated unsuccessfully
on four different occasions by various medical
teams coming because what would happen is
they would come, perform the initial surgery
and then never return.
And so it wasn't until ICSF came to Peru,
re-performed the initial surgery and was able
to return a year later for that critical post,
follow-up surgery that her treatment was finally
able to be successful.
This was a three-year-old Chinese girl who
suffered from a very rare cleft called tessier
number four bilateral orbital ocular cleft.
The problem in her case was similar to the
Pakistani man where there just weren't any
doctors in the area who had experience with
this particular cleft because it is so rare
and because it is such a lengthy surgery.
So it wasn't until a nearby hospital in the
city of Nanjing contacted ICSF that they were
able to come and perform the nine-hour surgery
that was witnessed by 20 local doctors that
her surgery, that her treatment was finally
able to be successful.
And then lastly burn victims.
This was a six-year-old Filipino girl.
Burn victims get left by the wayside time
and time again because the surgeries require
a little bit more expertise, take a little
bit longer.
And this is actually a kind of dramatic case
because it's a facial surgery but a lot of
times burn victims will have extreme burns
on their limbs.
So for example I was fortunate enough to get
to go to one of ICSF's missions that they
do every August in Lima at the Children's
Hospital there.
And there was a young boy there who had an
extreme burn on his arm and because of the
burn he actually had a web that connected
his bicep to his forearm and a second web
that connected his thumb to his wrist.
And so he had very little mobility in his
arm.
And so what you do is perform what's called
a Z-plasty where you rearrange the skin flaps
and all of a sudden you have mobility, the
kid can play sports and that type of thing.
Unfortunately if you were to take a before
and after picture it wouldn't look any better.
And so a lot of times burn victims just aren't
a very sexy cause and so not a lot of charities
address that and help burn victims.
It's not like clefts where all of the sudden
the kid has a new face and can smile afterwards
and everybody gets that warm and fuzzy.
Burn victims, it's not always so glorious
but it's no less important.
So again ICSF make sure to treat any kid that
can be treated including burn victims, including
some of the more complicated deformities and
I really like that about this charity.
That's the end of the slideshow, I do want
to go over the website a little bit.
Thanks Homer.
Oh questions, we'll go to that later.
Joyce put together a little like, she googlefied
the entire slide.
So this is the website, this is kind the hub
for the entire project, smiletrek.org.
And can you scroll down a little bit Homer?
So as you can see I try to maintain a blog
with photos, [whispers] Picasa albums.
[laughter]
And so if people want to keep up to date on
what's going on it's a good place to follow
the progress.
The next tab.
Okay so this is the route, oh actually scroll
down a little bit Homer, please thank you.
So I started at Singapore, I didn't quite
make it to Fuzhou which is where I'd wanted
to because my visa had expired and the Chinese
charge $100 a day for overstaying your visa.
So I flew to Taipei and I'll be heading all
the way to Kao-Chung and then down the Philippines
through Palawan.
And then Malaysia, Borneo and then back to
Singapore.
I hope to be back to Singapore no later than
late September early October.
Oh and thanks to Google latitudes it's actually,
you can track my location in real time.
So if any of you want to stalk me, you can
literally see where I am, you can zoom in
and actually see where I am at any given moment
cause I've got the latitudes in the GPS on
the phone.
And so actually, my mom will like e-mail me
in the morning and zoom in and be like "I
can see the little man moving."
[laughter]
So that's nice for people who want to track
the progress.
And then the last tab, I have a sponsors and
donors page.
So if any of you maybe know somebody, either
an organization or a business.
Can you scroll down a little bit Homer?
As you can see I give credit to my sponsors,
usually I put a little logo and the name of
the company and then a little blurb about
the company.
And then the logos actually link to their
website so that visitors can be linked to
the website of the sponsors.
And I just want to clarify that there's a
donate page here, but if you click the donate
page you will actually be rerouted to the
charities donation page.
So I don't touch any of the money it goes
directly to charity.
As far as my personal expenses I was able
to save up enough money in Afghanistan because
I didn't have too many expenses over there.
So I have more than enough in the bank to
sustain myself for a year in Southeast Asia.
So now the slides over, but questions if any
have any questions.
All right, thank you so much, no I'm just
joking.
[laughter]
Anybody?
>> Male #1: So how many, well actually I have
two questions and one's more out of curiosity.
A) how many doctors do you have in your network?
And then B) does your phone last all day in
terms of battery life?
>>Winston: I have a second battery, but it
actually does.
It'll make it, but the only reason it does
is because I take breaks and I charge it while
I take a break.
So when I'm grabbing a bite to eat I always
find a place to plug in.
And regarding the doctors ICSF,
[background noise]
The ghost of Google.
[laughter]
ICSF goes on about a dozen, they do a little
over a dozen medical missions a year.
Only about six of them, only on about six
of them do they take a team of doctors.
A lot of the times it's Dr. Williams who does
it full-time.
He's the only full-time doctor who partners
with the local doctors at the hospital, at
the same hospitals.
And only when they deploy to really kind of
secluded rural areas where there aren't a
lot of resources, they'll bring an anesthesiologist,
a handful of doctors, a nurse.
Does that answer your question?
>>Male #1: Yeah.
>>Winston: OK.
>>Joyce: Other locations feel free to ask
questions as well, just unmute yourselves.
Anymore questions from Taipei?
>>Winston: This guy's riding solo.
>>Joyce: [Laughing] Ming.
Ming you have a question?
>>Ming: Yeah I actually do.
This is great, I mean I'm impressed that you
have taken on one full year of yourself to
do this.
My question is how have you, what sort of
PR marketing have you done other than appearing
at Google?
Have you done any sort of promotion about
this?
>>Winston: Don't downplay this too much, this
is a big deal.
[laughter]
What other PR and marketing have I done?
I would say my Facebook page but that's such
a measly excuse for a Facebook page, it's
pretty bad.
Not much, not much man.
I try to take a weeklong break and all of
the capital cities.
So the route actually just connects the dots
of all the capital cities of the countries
I'm headed through for the most part.
And so I try to take a weeklong rest in those
cities and that's kind of my opportunity to
speak at Rotary clubs or international schools
and that type of thing.
Oh and whatever press I get along the way,
sometimes I get some press.
But I wouldn't say marketing I haven't done
any marketing.
Is he a marketing guy?
Is that why he's asking?
>>Ming: No no, you should try to put on kickstarter,
I bet you'd get some money.
>>Winston: They actually, kickstarter does
not allow fundraising for nonprofits.
>>Audinne: Oh
>>Ming: Oh they don't?
>>Winston: Yeah it's only creative products.
No they don't even, you can't, you can't even
have like a percentage of what you raise on
kickstarter go to a nonprofit.
It's exclusively creative projects.
>>Ming: I see.
>>Male # 2: A question in Tokyo.
>>Winston: All right.
>>Male # 2: Tokyo, so you obviously, I missed
the beginning of how long you've been on the
road but I assume traveling overland by foot
across Southeast Asia you've either learned
some lessons about the people or yourself
or something else.
Any interesting stories from the road?
>>Winston: Interesting stories.
>>Male # 2: Lessons learned, insights.
>>Winston: Yeah, the dogs in Thailand are
pretty bad.
[laughter]
There's so many strays and it's the first
thing that comes to mind as something out
of the blue.
A pack of stray dogs had run up on me on the
last day before getting into Bangkok at night.
And one of them bit me and broke the skin.
And I ended up, I had to go to get all vaccinations
and it was like set me back 300 bucks.
It was bad news.
So I've learned to stay away from the strays.
And then my umbrella became like a dog repellent
stick after that.
[laughter]
Yeah, I need to have more of these like spirit
question answers ready.
These like introspective answers ready.
Nothing comes to mind as far as like
>>Joyce: Talk about the guy in Vietnam that
you saw.
>>Winston: Yeah, that was, that would definitely
be the most heartfelt thing that happened,
what Joyce is bringing up.
It was kinda like one of those moments where
all of the stars aligned where I was heading,
I was in northern Vietnam heading towards
the Chinese border.
And all the sudden I see this guy on a scooter
right past me and he had FPN, facial plexiform
neurofibromatosis the elephant man syndrome
like in the slide I showed you.
And it was a pretty severe case of it.
And I knew that this was something that ICSF
tackled and that they addressed.
And luckily he actually stopped at a fish
market behind me.
And I'm hoping this story will charm you because
it involves Google Translate.
[laughter]
I, and at that moment I realized, I put two
and two together and realized that it just
so happened that one of ICSF's annual missions
is at the Children's Hospital in the Haiphong
was less than 100 miles north of where I was.
That I was gonna be passing through.
And it was gonna be a couple months from then.
So I turn around and pretend that I'm browsing
the fish market, I've got like my suit on
and like totally fit in.
Then I open Google Translate on my phone and
I type in something to the extent of "Hey
would you be interested in a free surgery?"
And he was interested and we had a couple
back and forth and I relayed some more details
to him and got his information, got his phone
number.
And made it up to Haiphong and sat down with
the doctor there that ICSF works with.
And they were able to; he was able to show
up.
I recently learned a couple days ago, the
mission was about a week ago that there was
actually a greater than usual turnout this
year so there were actually more children
than could be cared for.
And children are the priority.
ICSF actually prioritizes children first,
shame on them.
And so they actually, his schedule, his surgery
is gonna have to be scheduled for next year's
mission.
But ICSF already agreed to spend an additional
week at that particular mission to make sure
that they can get through all the surgeries
next year.
So unfortunately he didn't get treated this
time around but he will next May.
But does that answer your question?
Is he still there?
>>Joyce: Yeah, they're still there.
>>Winston: Okay.
>>Joyce: I think Singapore has a question
next.
Singapore?
>>Celine: Hi Winston.
>>Winston: Hi.
>>Celine: This is Celine, It's nice to see
you.
>>Winston: Hey how's it going?
>>Celine: It's going well, good to see you.
We look forward to meeting you when you get
to Singapore.
>>Winston: Thank you, it's Celine?
>>Celine: Yes.
I have two questions, one is how involved
are you in how the money you're collecting
is being spent by the foundation?
I'm sure you trust their expertise but have
you given them some ideas in terms of how
you want that money to be utilized?
[Inaudible] and then spend it how they think
is fit?
>>Winston: Okay.
>>Celine: And my second question, once you
complete this journey what are you going to
do?
Do you have another journey in mind [Inaudible]
>>Winston: Okay so how does the charity spend
their money and what am I gonna do after this?
So the money goes directly to the charity
so they're actually, it's not like I'm gonna
give them one big lump sum at the end and
then tell them have fun.
It's being allocated to them every time somebody
makes a donation.
As far as how they spend, the majority almost
all of their spending is actually on the plane
tickets to get on transportation to get the
doctors on the mission site.
The second greatest expense are all of the
medical expenses.
So the surgeries are 100% free to the patient's
and that means that ICSF picks up the tab
for the oxygen tanks, all of the medicine
that goes along with the surgeries.
All of the stitches the sutures.
The hospitals that they partner with a lot
of times will let them have the operating
room for free which is great, that's one less
expense.
And sometimes if a patient lives kinda far
out from where the mission takes place, ICSF
will pick up the tab for their transportation
and make sure that they get there.
And after that it's very little, that's really
the meat and potatoes of how they spend their
money.
As far as where they stay, because they return
to the same mission sites and have those local
connections a lot of times they're put up
by, like the mission I went to in Lima he
stays with the doctors, in the home of the
doctors that he works with.
So he stayed with one of the doctors that
he's been working with ever since that mission
kicked off 12 years ago.
So he doesn't pay for a place to stay, they
drop him off at the hospital and take him
back home so there's no taxi expenses.
While I was there they fed us, so they would
bring us food.
So he didn't spend any money on food.
Like in the Philippines for example they've
hooked up with a local Rotarian who owns a
hotel there.
So he's put up by Rotarians when he goes there.
So it's only in a few cases that he actually
has to spend money on a place to stay.
And as far as the overhead at home, it's literally,
the office is literally like the basement
of the Idaho home in Boise Idaho.
His mother is retired who's doing all of the
secretarial work and responsibilities and
stuff.
So literally there's only two full-time employees,
him and his mother at home.
And then there's one full-time nurse coordinator
in the Philippines because they have more
missions in the Philippines and anywhere else.
About three or four every year.
So they have one full-time coordinator there
who also volunteers for free.
Does that, does that answer your first question?
Celine?
>>Celine: Yes it does thank you.
>>Winston: Okay.
In regards to your second question, I have
recently become incredibly inspired by the
urban farming movement.
Totally under the spell of urban farming these
days.
And I'd like to explore that as much is possible
when I get back.
I want to learn as much about urban agriculture
as possible.
So urban farming is the practice of using
untraditional spaces to grow food.
So like growing food on your rooftop which
is a space that would otherwise go to waste.
But which is a great space to grow food a
lot of times.
Farming fish in your basement.
That type of thing.
And so using all this space that is not going
to use to grow food.
And the more I research it the more inspired
I am.
It's absolutely incredible how much food you
grow in such a compact area if you're doing
it right.
And it's all about high efficient yields and
hydroponics and it's a very interesting to
me.
So I hope to learn as much about that as possible
and I hope to make that the next chapter of
my life.
Definitely not gonna be doing any walking
after this anytime soon.
[laughter]
Any other questions?
>>Joyce: Show us your backpack.
>>Winston: Oh yeah I forgot about the rig.
So this is my home.
It has been since I kicked off in October.
So I have everything I need here.
I have my tent which weighs about 2 pounds.
An inflatable sleeping mattress, sleeping
bag I can carry up to 4 liters of water and
then some miscellaneous electronics.
And I actually carry a Mac Book air in the
back.
[laughter]
And this is it, it's really basic.
Because I'm not trekking in the middle of
nowhere and I'm on main roads, I can pick
up food along the way.
Finding a place to eat has not been a problem
so far.
And so it's able to be a pretty lean set up.
It weighs about 20 pounds.
>>Male # 3: So I have a quick question here
from Sydney.
>>Winston: Yeah.
>>Male # 3: So I'm walking to work once in
a while, and that's about 3 km.
It takes me like 20 minutes and I get kinda
bored along the way once in a while.
So I'm curious how do you keep yourself avoiding
this?
How do you save this?
What do you do on a bad day?
Do you sing or do listen to your iPod or what
you do to stay with it?
>>Winston: Yeah it's not singing, it's the
iPod.
[laughter]
Yeah I listen to; I need to get some new music
actually.
Because I've been listening to the same songs
for a while now.
I listen to music, I listen to various podcasts
and talks and interviews and that type of
thing to kinda keep myself from going crazy.
And yeah that's it.
>>Male # 3: Do you have days where you feel
like you want to throw it all away or you
feel like you just want it to end?
>>Winston: Well you know the nice thing about,
no it hasn't reached that point.
I mean if there is a day where I'm just excessively
exhausted or something then I can just rest
for a day and then start the next day.
So it's not, know that hasn't been any major
incident that just makes me want to drop pack
and get on a plane.
[laughter]
>>Male # 3: Apart from the dogs in Thailand.
>>Winston: Yeah those dogs.
[laughter]
>>Male # 3: Thanks.
>>Joyce: Any more questions?
Yeah.
>>Male # 4: You seem to be spending nights
camping, having your own little house to set
up and sleep.
And you're obviously not in the wilderness.
Most of Southeast Asia is extremely populated,
morning, evening, nightly there's always somebody
walking by.
How do you manage that?
>>Winston: Yeah, that's definitely an understatement,
this places that are very populated.
How do I manage so many people?
Is that your question?
>>Male # 4: Yeah.
When you're sleeping, obviously it's not like
there's a campground.
It's not like it's protected, all that kind
of stuff.
>>Winston: Yeah, it can, well I've been, I
did a lot of camping in Malaysia for the first
part of the trip because guesthouses and hotels
were still kind of too pricey.
And then once I got into Thailand, guesthouses
started to be like you know 10 bucks or less
a night.
And for that amount of money it's not worth
not staying in a guesthouse.
Like you've got air conditioning so your socks
can dry.
You've got, you can take a shower.
The list goes on of the advantages of not
camping.
So, but when I do camp I try to find a more
secluded spot where dogs aren't barking or
roosters aren't crowing.
Or like I remember in Malaysia it's impossible,
it's physically impossible to be anywhere
where you're not within earshot of a mosque.
And so like 5:30 in the morning you get woken
up by the prayers.
>>Male # 4: So have you considered staying
with people?
I mean have you are welcome to stay at my
place if you happen to go by.
>>Winston: Thanks man, where's this?
>>Male # 4: India.
>>Winston: India.
>>Male # 4: However there are sites like couch
surfing etc. where you can just stay with
a local who's willing to invite you.
That could also be a good way to immerse yourself
in the local culture and be able to make a
bigger impact.
>>Winston: Couch surfing huh?
I actually, I'm a coucher for myself.
I brought my couch surfing host here today
for the presentation.
Her mother and herself have been very generous
in hosting me, putting me up for the week.
And I try to couch surf, couch surfing is
more for like when I'm in a pause somewhere
in a big city for a week or so.
It's a little tougher to coordinate any other
time just because I'm never quite sure when
I'm gonna arrive somewhere.
When traveling on foot.
But couch surfing has been an amazing resource.
I mean it's obviously great to have a free
place to stay.
But just to have somebody who can tell you
okay this is a tourist trap, this neighborhood
stay away from this neighborhood.
Maybe it's dangerous or something.
And make recommendations and a great way to
meet people and just make friends.
So yeah I'm a huge proponent of couch surfing.
So can I couch surf your place in India?
>>Male # 4: For sure.
And Hyderabad is a big city.
>>Winston: Yah.
Thank you.
>>Male # 5: So one question here, how does
the organization check for doctors to join
the group?
Is there any doctor from Taiwan?
>>Winston: Good question.
>>Male # 5: And the second one is actually
Google has trip credit it can donate, so if
you can contact with someone inside Google
who can make that happen we can probably donate
lots of trip credit.
>>Winston: Well this would be the place to
do that.
If you're able to find somebody at Google
somewhere who can help you, you should jump
on that.
>>Joyce: So if I can just jump in, so Google
has set up gift matching.
So if you donate on Winston's website you
can just basically tell Google how much money
you've donated and Google will match whatever
you given already to ICFS.
But you might be seeing something from Google,
if Googlers individually decide to give reporting
on gift matching.
Oh that's great news, that awesome.
So to answer your question, I'm not sure.
I know they don't have any missions in Taiwan.
And I don't think any of the doctors that
ICSF partners with happen to the Taiwanese.
But I'm not 100% sure on that.
I can ask and get back to you.
And then I think you had a follow-up question.
I was just about the trip.
>>Male # 5: Actually trip credit is a different
thing is sort gift matching.
So I'm not sure who can help on that.
>>Winston: Yeah I wish I knew somebody.
>>Joyce: Any more questions?
>>Male # 6: Yeah we have a question in Tokyo.
Hello.
>>Winston: Hello.
>>Male # 6: I'm just trying to picture how
big the problem is.
Like how many people when you get to see while
you're traveling with that problem?
What I'm trying to say is if you just can
met with the people with that problem in the
random level, I think it's a very big problem
that should be solved on the macro level.
That's what I'm thinking.
>>Winston: Yeah absolutely.
Luckily I did not see, or I don't know if
it's luckily or not.
I did not see a child with a cleft until Hanoi
Vietnam.
And that was because I was visiting a local
charity there, a Vietnamese medical organization
that provides cleft surgeries for local Vietnamese
kids.
And I got a tour of their organization and
there happened to be some kids there who were
waiting for surgery by who I got to meet.
Other than that I haven't seen any really
just out and about.
I've seen a couple who had had clefts that
you could see there was some scarring so they
had clefts that have been repaired which is
great.
But I didn't see too many out and about or
I haven't so far.
I don't know if that's a good thing or maybe,
maybe they're not anxious to go out and be
seen the public.
You know who knows.
But that's been my experience with kids with
class so far in this region.
>>Male # 6: Okay thank you.
>>Winston: Thank you.
>>Joyce: Any more questions?
>>Female # 1: You said that there are more
kids with cleft palates in Southeast Asia
and there are in other areas.
>>Winston: Yeah that brings me to something
I hadn't mentioned.
The reason I chose to focus the trek in Southeast
Asia was primarily because I've never been
in this part of the world before.
And also believe it or not they're actually
slightly more occurrences of cleft births
in this region than other parts of the world
for whatever reason.
So that's why I wanted to kind of focus things
in Southeast Asia.
Philippines are actually pretty bad.
I think it's like one out of every 600 or
something like that, 6 to 800.
And it just so happens that ICSF has a medical
mission that's going on there in July and
It's going to coincide with me passing through.
So I'm gonna be able to get to visit the medical
mission and hang out there for a couple weeks
and get to meet some of the families firsthand.
Which should be pretty cool, I'll take lots
of pictures.
All right.
>>Joyce: Anyone else have questions?
Any other offices?
If not
>>Winston: Get some fried chicken.
[laughter]
>>Joyce: Thanks so much Winston.
>>Winston: Thank you, thank you very much.
[applause]